if you can get out of the
finger-pointing business and get into
the thumbs business your life will be
dramatically better like dramatically
because here's the problem the reason
everyone's on angst the reason
everyone's so challenged is because when
you point fingers you just admitted that
you're not in control period
accountability is such a powerful drug
and it is something we have lost our way
with we just have we need to get there
you can't tell me anything you can come
up here and fully explain why it's not
working and I can look right here with
your current job and I could say quit
you could you are in control unlike
where I and my parents were born you're
born in a place where you can quit and
you can change your career you can move
you can do anything and the second you
start understanding that truth is the
second everything opens up